what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
chief keith the talk as you guys know i
have reacted
to the national anthem that he put out a
couple years ago
love sosa and it was a great song so
i'm gonna react interpret the lyrics and
tell you guys
what i think but before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
guys i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers this month
help a girl out okay
oh man oh man i'm bopping my head
okay
okay so he's saying that he just got his
he just got a i don't know if i can say
this on youtube but a b
j so he's getting sexual favors from
women
[Music]
okay so he's letting you know you might
have dropped some songs
they might have been okay but you don't
create national anthems
like i do tell them
okay so he's letting you know that he is
rougher and more hood than you
he's letting you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh no oh he killed his friend
he said your homie just died keep your
head up i think that was a threat
damn first
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's just letting you know all
the cool things he does
in his day-to-day activities sounds like
there's some drugs there's some guns
um sounds like he went to jail for a
minute i don't know
i don't talk much i'm a quiet guy
all right do they play basketball i saw
hoop chief keef i challenge you to one
on one i'm doing it now
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so he said ben franklin is his
friend
um and he's talking about money he gets
money
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so he just got fresh as f so that means
that he looks
good
[Music]
[Music]
oh so he's inviting his friends to his
show
what an what a nice guy
they got a lot of he's got a lot of
friends every music video chief keef is
in
he has got friends for days
and when he says gang he doesn't just
mean like homies like i think he's in an
actual gang
okay guys i think the video's over skill
one to five
um i'm gonna give this video
a five i mean honestly chief keef this
is what he does he creates
national anthems and he did it again we
have a new national anthem
before i end the video guys don't forget
to subscribe to the channel okay
ring that notification bell while you're
at it
and i'm going to talk to you guys next